l'application fait sap est devenu viral
depuis le début de la semaine
même dans cette populaire émission
matinale américaine
elle permet d'utiliser votre photo et de
vous faire vieillir de quelques dizaines
d'années
les résultats sont surprenants ou
parfois dérangeant l'application qui a
plus de 80 millions d'utilisateurs à
travers le monde propose depuis 2010 est
de modifier votre apparence couleur
d'yeux coupe de cheveux barbe tout est
possible mais depuis deux jours l'option
de se vieillir le fait sap challenge
fait probablement fureur dans tous les
fils d'actualités de vos réseaux sociaux
que ce soit les célébrités d'ici ou bien
d'ailleurs bien du monde se prête au jeu
de l'application qui utilisent
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est pour aller enrichir les bases de
données qui vont servir entraîné une
intelligence artificielle qui va
apprendre de nos photos a de plus être
de plus en plus près c'est justement
pour rajeunir une photo vieillie une
photo changé par exemple à une l'aspect
de quelqu'un alors est ce vraiment
inoffensif s'essayer à tous une le
produit
la première question reste posée quand
on est en application ses premiers font
de l'argent
d'où vient leur argent khider et
d'application dans sa politique de
confidentialité fait simple mentionne
qu'elle enregistre les photos et leurs
métadonnées ainsi que les informations
personnelles des utilisateurs leur
localisation géographique et leur
historique de navigation on donne à
l'application la possibilité de prendre
ses photos et des captures et et les
envoyer vers des saveurs qui peuvent
être situés dans d'autres pays
l'entreprise qui a développé
l'application est russe et son serveur
est situé aux états unis ce qui peut
compliquer les choses en cas de problème
on peut pas contrôler et de mère légale
ou demande structurelle at ravageant des
standards sécurité de l'information ou à
travers un cadre légal dit mais vous
pourrez poser ses données biométriques
là afin de leur vendre un acteur et que
ça ne reviendra sans criminels y donc il
ya énormément d'argent à ce niveau là
bref la prudence reste de mise même si
tout est relatif dans votre univers
numérique
vous avez publié hier des photos de
votre party d'anniversaire
vous avez des photos de vos enfants de
vos animaux domestiques et pourtant là
c'est une poussée cette application le
qui vient justement chatouiller la votre
côté chapelle reste d'empêcher les gens
touchent à vos données
ici dans de très très longues années
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal